and there's a great myth about the Lord
Chancellor and the Lord great
Chamberlain and Earl marshal walking
backwards which used to happen at the
state openings but for more than twenty
years there's been no walking backwards
everybody turns round and the theory was
he couldn't turn you back on the wall
you that was the theory and so I suppose
it's of note he recovers with the purse
containing as the speech
[Music]
well above the MP for spring today
my Lords and members of the House of
Commons my government's priority has
always been to secure the United
Kingdom's departure from the European
Union on the 31st of October my
government intends to work towards a new
partnership with the European Union
based on free trade and friendly
cooperation my ministers will work to
implement new regimes for Fisheries
agriculture and trade seizing the
opportunities that arise from leaving
the European Union an immigration bill
ending free movement will lay the
foundation for a fair modern and global
immigration system my government remains
committed to ensuring that resident
European citizens who have built their
lives in and contributed so much to the
United Kingdom have the right to remain
the bill will include measures that
reinforce this commitment steps will be
taken to provide certainty stability and
new opportunities for the financial
services and legal sectors my
government's new economic plan will be
underpinned by a responsible fiscal
strategy investing in economic growth
while maintaining the sustainability of
the public finances measures will be
brought forward to support and
strengthen the National Health Service
its workforce and resources enabling it
to deliver the highest quality care new
laws will be taken forward to help
implement the national health services
long-term plan in England and to
establish an independent body to
investigate serious health care
incidents my government will bring
forward proposals to reform adult social
care in England to ensure dignity in old
age my ministers will
tinu work to reform the Mental Health
Act to improve respect for and care of
their is receiving treatment my
government is committed to addressing
violent crime and to strengthening
public confidence in the criminal
justice system new sentencing laws will
see that the most serious offenders
spend longer in custody to reflect
better the severity of their crimes
measures will be introduced to improve
the justice system's response to foreign
national offenders my government will
work to improve safety and security in
prisons and to strengthen the
rehabilitation of offenders proposals
will be brought forward to ensure that
victims receive the support they need
and the Justice they deserve laws will
be introduced to ensure that the parole
system recognizes the paint victims and
their families caused by offenders
refusing to disclose information
relating to their crimes a new duty will
be placed on public sector bodies
ensuring they work together to address
serious violence police officers will be
provided with the protections they need
to keep the population safe they will
also be awarded the power to arrest
individuals who are wanted by trusted
international partners my government
will bring forward measures to protect
individuals families and their homes
legislation will transform the approach
of the justice system and other agencies
to victims of domestic abuse and
minimize the impact of divorce
particularly on children my ministers
will continue to develop proposals to
improve Internet safety and will bring
forward laws to implement new building
safety standards
my ministers will ensure that all young
people have access to an excellent
education unlocking their full potential
and preparing them for the world of work
my government will take steps to make
work fairer introducing measures that
will support those working hard to help
people plan for the future measures will
be brought forward to provide simpler
oversight of pension savings to protect
people savings for later life new laws
will provide greater powers to tackle
irresponsible management of private
pension schemes to ensure that the
benefits of a prospering economy reach
every corner of the United Kingdom my
ministers will bring forward a national
infrastructure strategy this will set
out a long-term vision to improve the
nation's digital transport and energy
infrastructure new legislation will help
accelerate the delivery of fast reliable
and secure broadband networks to
millions of homes an aviation bill will
provide for the effective and efficient
management of the United Kingdom's
airspace proposals on railway reform
will be brought forward a white paper
will publish be published to set out by
government's ambitions for unleashing
regional potential in England and to
enable decisions that affect local
people to be made at a local level my
government is committed to establishing
the United Kingdom as a world leader in
scientific capability and space
technology increased investment in
science will be complemented by the
development of a new funding agency a
more open visa system and an ambitious
national space strategy
my ministers remain committed to
protecting and improving the environment
for future generations for the first
time environmental principles will be
enshrined in law measures will be
introduced to improve air and water
quality tackle plastic pollution and
restore habitats so plants and wildlife
can thrive legislation will also create
new legally binding environmental
improvement targets a new world leading
independent regulator will be
established in statute to scrutinize
environmental policy and law investigate
complaints and take enforcement action
proposals will also be brought forward
to promote and protect the welfare of
animals including banning imports from
trophy hunting the integrity and
prosperity of the Union that binds the
four nations of the United Kingdom is of
the utmost importance to my government
my ministers will bring forward measures
to support citizens across all the
nations of the United Kingdom my
government remains committed to working
with all parties in Northern Ireland to
support the return of devolved
government and to address the legacy of
the past my government will take steps
to protect the integrity of democracy
and the electoral system in the United
Kingdom my government will continue to
invest in our gallant Armed Forces my
ministers will honor the Armed Forces
covenant and the NATO commitment to
spend at least two percent of national
income on defence as the United Kingdom
leaves the European Union my government
will ensure that it continues to play a
lead
in global affairs defending his
interests and promoting its values my
government will be at the forefront of
efforts to solve the most complex
international security issues it will
champion global free trade and work
alongside international partners to
solve the most pressing global
challenges it will prioritized tackling
climate change and ensuring that all
girls have access to 12 years of quality
education members of the House of
Commons estimates for the public
services will be laid before you my
Lords and members of the House of
Commons other measures will be laid
before you I pray that the blessing of
Almighty God may rest upon your counsels
so now the lord transyl of retrieves the
text of the speech and puts it in his
purse and after her majesty and prince
charles there the earth or throne
sitting next to her have processed out
with the pages carrying the train we
will then see the mps returned to the
House of Commons steps up to the throne
which even the monarch has to navigate